ja wie kann das sein diese Frage stellt
sich jeden Tag dringlicher auch im Fall
der ermordeten 14-jährigen Eileen warum
wurde ihr mutmaßlicher Mörder ein
verurteilter Sexualstraftäter mit
offenbar psychischen Problemen aus der
staatlichen beobachtet Beobachtung in
die uneingeschränkte Freiheit entlassen
je länger wir recherchieren je mehr
Hinweise finden wir die Polizei und
Behörden auch hatten und die klar
dagegen sprachen
ein Mann in einem Zug sein Arm lehnt
lässig auf der Kopfstütze der Mann dreht
sich zu seiner Rückbank um zu seinem
potenziellen Opfer dieses Foto
aufgenommen von einem 14-jährigen
Mädchen weil sie sich von diesem Mann
belästigt fühlt von Jan Heiko P Aileens
mutmaßlich Mörder März 2022 die
14-Jährige Julia steht mit ihrer kleinen
Schwester am Bahnhof brandoberndorf die
Mädchen sind auf dem Weg zu ihrer
Großmutter Julias Vater schildert
exklusiv in Bild was geschieht am
Bahnhof ist ihr schon der Mann
aufgefallen der wahrscheinlich schon auf
kleine Mädchen gewartet hat er kommt
ihnen immer näher im Zug setzen sich die
Mädchen weit weg von Jan Heiko P doch
ihr folgt ihnen wirft ihnen einen Ball
zu möchte er sie Ködern Jan Heiko P
beugt sich zu Julia herunter bedrängt
sie in diesem Moment nimmt Julia das
Foto ihres Verfolgers auf doch Jan Heiko
P ist nicht zu stoppen er hatte meine
Tochter begrapscht er hat ihr auf den Po
gehauen mit Hilfe von Julia sandyfoto
kann der Vater Jan Heiko P
identifizieren meldet ihn bei der
Polizei unfassbar die Polizei sagt ihm
sie hätten Jan Heiko P bereits im Visier
doch passiert ist nichts mal wieder denn
Jan Heiko PS ermittlungsliste ist lang
immer wieder soll er Kinder belästigen
Konsequenzen hatte das meist nicht schon
als Kind soll Jan Heiko P kleine Mädchen
im Schwimmbad taunusperle belästigt
haben die Freibad Pächterin stellt ihn
damals zur Rede doch Jan Heiko P ist
unbelehrbar neun Jahre später fällt Jan
Heiko P über ein elfjähriges Mädchen her
hier wirkte das kleine Mädchen fast zu
Tode versucht es zu vergewaltigen
Kinder verurteilt Jan Heiko P unter
anderem wegen versuchter Vergewaltigung
der damals Jugendliche kommt in die
psychiatrische Klinik zehn Jahre später
kommt Jan Heiko P aus der Klinik als
rückfallgefährdeter Sexualstraftäter
steht dafür drei Jahre unter
Führungsaufsicht trotz behördlicher
Beobachtung reist Jan Heiko P nach
Berlin und bedrängt Schlagerstar
Annemarie Eilfeld ein Bekannter erzählt
Bild exklusiv Jan Heiko P soll seine
Ex-Freundin vergewaltigt haben sie
erstattet Anzeige doch das Verfahren
wird eingestellt im Januar 2020 endet
die Führungsaufsicht des triebtäters
diese soll eigentlich verlängert werden
doch Jan Heiko P beschwert sich das
Gericht verlängert die Beobachtung nur
für zwei Jahre doch nur wenige Monate
später soll Jan Heiko P erneut
zuschlagen in einem Garten soll er ein
zwölfjähriges Mädchen belästigt haben
seine Mutter soll Jan Heiko P daraufhin
ange haben kein Grund für die Behörden
die Führungsaufsicht zu verlängern im
Januar 2022 läuft diese aus
unkontrolliert treibt sich an Heiko P
weiter durch Deutschland auf einem Fest
in Hessen soll er eine 17-Jährige massiv
bedrängen und ihr nachstellen folgt ihr
sogar bis zu ihrer Schule das Mädchen
zeigt ihn an nach Bildinformationen gibt
es lediglich eine gefährdeansprache dann
der grausame Mord an Eileen am 29 juli
nehmen Ermittler den 29-Jährigen fest
mutmaßlich soll er die 14-Jährige online
geködert verschleppt und ermordet haben
ihre Leiche finden die Ermittler im
teufelsee wenige Kilometer von Jan Heiko
pees Wohnort entfernt nur 29 Jahre auf
der Welt und mindestens zwölf Mal soll
Jan Heiko P Kinder und Frauen belästigt
bedrängt und nun mutmaßlich ermordet
haben in aller Öffentlichkeit begeht Jan
Heiko seine Taten als fühle er sich
sicher und geschützt im Schatten des
deutschen Justizsystems
[Musik]
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit Thorsten
Schleifer ist Vorsitzender Richter am
Schaffen Gericht den dienstlaken und
Buchautor genannte schleif guten Abend
Bücher darüber geschrieben wo unser
Justizsystem versagt wenn wir jetzt
diese Kette der Ereignisse sehen sie
haben gerade auch mitbekommen was ihr
Fazit
ja eindeutiges Versagen nicht nur der
Justiz sondern möglicherweise auch der
Polizeibehörden ganz tragisch ist wenn
man bedenkt dass der Amtsrichter in
Wetzlar ja erkannt hat dass da weiterhin
ein Gefährdungspotenzial da ist und
deswegen die Führungsaufsicht
unbefristet verlängert hat hat er das
ganze auch gesehen erst das Landgericht
Limburg hat ja dann das Amt ganz anders
eingestuft und gesagt wir sehen das
Gefährdungspotenzial nicht so wie das
Amtsgericht und hat deswegen auch
tatsächlich die aufbeschwerde des
Verurteilten hin die Führungsaufsicht
nur um zwei Jahre verlängert ja genau
also fünf Jahre insgesamt ist er bei ja
beobachtet worden stand unter
staatlicher Beobachtung sozusagen wie
konnte man in dieser Zeit nicht bemerken
dass er weiter gefährlich sein könnte
wie gesagt der Amtsrichter scheint es ja
sogar bemerkt zu haben das war Herr der
Grund für die Verlängerung der
Führungsaufsicht man muss immer bedenken
während der Führungsaufsicht erhält man
regelmäßig noch einen Bewährungshelfer
und da kommt es natürlich einerseits auf
das persönliche Engagement des
Bewährungshelfers an das sind
Sozialarbeiter die für den ambulanten
sozialen Dienst der Justiz zuständig
sind und natürlich auch wie viele
Klienten hat der jeweilige
Sozialarbeiter und wie viele muss er
sich kümmern und auch da ist wie fast
überall in der Justiz natürlich auf Not
am Mann das heißt da sind starke
unterbesetzungen da möglicherweise hat
das auch hier wieder eine Rolle gespielt
wir haben gehört eine Vater hatte
Anzeige bei der Polizei erstattet nach
einem Vorfall im Zug auch da offenbar
dann nichts weiter passiert
ja das richtige hat offensichtlich nur
diese eine einzige gefährderansprache
gegeben und das ist natürlich zu wenig
hier hätte viel mehr Einsatz und
Konsequenz gezeigt werden müssen ich
kenne auch Polizeibeamten die ganz klar
gemacht hätten junge wir haben dich im
Blick ein falscher Schritt und wir sind
da
könnt ihr Eileen noch leben wenn es eine
größere Aufmerksamkeit gegeben hätte
das ist natürlich reine Spekulation
allerdings ist eins nicht von der Hand
zu weisen wäre die Führungsaufsicht
angeordnet gewesen weiterhin wir Sie
also nicht aufgehoben worden und hätte
die Polizei mehr Einsatz und mehr
Konsequenz gezeigt dann wäre es sehr
viel wahrscheinlicher gewesen dass die
Vorbereitungshandlungen des mutmaßlichen
Täters insbesondere die Kontaktaufnahme
zu Eileen aufgefallen wäre und dann ein
rechtzeitiges einschreiten noch möglich
gewesen wäre was muss ich also ändern
es muss ich einiges ändern vor allem
muss meiner Meinung nach sofort bei der
ersten Verurteilung eines pädophilen
Sexualstraftäters eine unbefristete
Führungsaufsicht angeordnet werden da
muss eine gesetzliche Änderung her es
darf nicht sein dass ein Pädophiler
Sexualstraftäter bei denen wir
Rückfallquoten von etwa 80 Prozent haben
nach neuesten studienlagen dass die
irgendwann wieder aus dem Raster
rausfallen
vielen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung
[Musik]